Donald Trump has actually said he will
generously offer up his time and energy
to serve as interim speaker of the house
to help unify the Republicans said he'll
be the great unifier that's what he's
going to do and I am just begging all of
you please I employ you I'm looking into
the eyes of every Republican member of
Congress right now do what you know must
be done nominate second and vote for
Donald Trump as Speaker of the House
give the people what they want now got
to be honest I actually think there's a
strong possibility it could happen right
now I mean strong doesn't mean greater
than majority doesn't mean 90% but I'm
also wondering because nobody really
wants to do it there's a handful I mean
scales wants to do it Jim Jordan wants
to do it they'll probably go in that
direction but there is perhaps at least
a single digit or double digit
percentage chance that if Donald Trump
gets the nomination many Republicans
will be concerned that if they don't
support him it could be bad for them
considering Donald Trump is polling so
well right now